so my name is Ron Dobbs I'm a data
scientist at pivotal in Berlin and today
I'll present you hopefully this live
demo and if it works then it will be one
of the most exciting talks were here at
PI data London and this is certainly the
only presentation that is potential for
bodily harm and then manslaughter all
right everything I showed today will is
on github actually it's all open source
so how did this project come about we
did a really cool project for customer
it has it had fast data ingestion it had
thousands of clients and there was a
really good IOT project and it has real
time analytics was a dashboard but sadly
it was covered with an ironclad NDA so
we could not show it so we got thinking
how can we demo this technology we built
so we came up with the connected car
everybody is familiar with a car
everybody can relate to a car especially
a German like me can especially later
car and ok so the pieces were really all
the same we had a wet spring XD for data
ingestion we used HDFS for storage so
Hadoop and we use the PI data stack for
analytics and we use gemfire which is
now known as a project geode it's an
open-source Apache Incubator project as
a data cache for the for the dashboard
we came up with two use cases one of
them being to predict the destination of
the driver without the driver having to
enter anything into the satellite
navigation system based on past driver
behavior number two once we've predicted
where somebody is going we can then
based on his driving habits and Driver
profile very accurately predict this
remaining range which is very important
for for all right he's on ok which is
very important for for electric cars
especially a quick overview of the
architecture we start in a car we stream
data to the car using an obd2 bluetooth
dongle onto onto an app we Christ and
Herbie it's a mobile phone app we
develop for iOS
then posts the data to server in the
cloud and the server then displays the
results of our models and some real-time
sensor data on a dashboard now it's just
a very rough overview I'll go into
details on a moment now we have somebody
sitting in a car your non on waiting to
drive so we switch over to him couldn't
get a live video feed so we have am on
the phone right now maxime can you hear
us yeah yeah I'm here yes we can hear
you could you so we're going to have a
look at the dashboard now and could you
could you wrap your car for us let's
wait let's set up the dashboard here all
right yeah and really do something okay
perfect so this is all real times it's
not pre-recorded so he's revving his car
is positioned here and why don't why
don't you introduce yourself and tell us
where you could be going today yeah I'm
fine in 15 I will give it a lot this
year so I will be driving today to a
notification I'm driving from occasion
for problems over five and yes you
actually how long without getting we're
all right let's get started then why why
don't you start driving and we can we
can start seeing some some data
streaming and so by the way this is this
is the dashboard we built up here is a
selector of the car we want to follow so
this actually supports multiple cars but
we're following a PI data alone on car
today this is the RPM that's streaming
live from the car we can see the speed
here we've got the coolant temperature
we have information here about the fuel
it's in the car there and we also on a
second pain here it's actually the more
interesting pain
so this is the blue dot a secure
location of Maxim and the orange dots
these are his potential destinations so
this is these are destinations he's gone
to previously and these here are the
associated probabilities of these
destinations and the latitude and
longitude of those destinations this is
the predicted range how much we predict
he still has in his tank with this
driver behavior and how much fuel is
using okay right now okay but we'll get
back to that later in more detail lets
me let me switch back to the
presentation while Maxime will do his
drive to an undisclosed location all
right so perfect all right so how does
all of this work let's start in the car
every car since the end of the 90s has
something called an on-board diagnostics
port this onboard diagnostic port can
deliver sensor information from that car
then we use this port to plug a very
cheap bluetooth dongle in there that is
able to relay that data in real time to
the phone app we build Herbie and via
cellular from the phone we post this
data to the server in the clouds and we
also enrich the data with GPS
coordinates and acceleration from the
phone so we use the accelerometer in the
phone and to do that this is an example
of a data block we get here so so we
transform this data into Jason we get a
bunch of sensor data use for example the
coolant temperature that I showed but
also throttle position and a lot of
other values of course real real car
manufacturers they have access to a lot
more data but this is this is like the
publicly available data anybody can pull
out of this port so let's focus on on
how this looks on the server side we use
a TCP socket to stream the data over
Bluetooth to the phone and then we use
HTTP HTTP POST to just stream it to the
server and then from this formula from
the server way we relate to the
dashboard so what's installed on the
server
we have a project called spring XD you
may not have heard of this project but
it's an open source project it's
basically a domain-specific language for
real-time data workflows it's modeled
after unix pipelines and it supports
Python and it's it's really cool project
and it does a lot of orchestration
around real-time pipelines it's really
useful and I urge everybody to check it
out it does really cool things like load
balancing for example so if you if you
want to put models into production and
load balance these models it can handle
that for you and it really is able to
scale up a lot the way it looks in our
architecture so we we ingest the data
and spring XD and splits the data stream
into two so one for storage we put it in
Hadoop and for real-time display on gem
on a dashboard we put it in gemfire
which is our real-time in-memory
database also the open-source version as
I mentioned is called Project geode now
from there from jump higher without then
able to display this on the dashboard we
just saw spring XD handles ingest
ingestion orchestration extraction and
the real-time analytics and the spring
st is able to run in a distributed
manner on multiple machines we can both
launch streaming and batch jobs from
within spring XD well spring XD both has
a has a console you can enter commands
and but also a graphical user interface
as I've mentioned spring XD is modeled
after UNIX pipelines so this is a
simplified thing of what we simplified
pipeline of what we're doing here in
this demo we have an HTTP source so it's
receiving data from HTTP from from the
phone from the app and then we filter
the data clean it up a little bit then
we enrich the data was for example a
timestamp and a unique journey idea and
such things I'll get into this a little
bit later and then we have a shell
comment where we can pipe the out output
to any processor in this case we use
pison we look with preload models into
pies
into memory and then the shell module is
able to score the models we developed in
real time and we output all the data
into HDFS now this of course only saves
the data in HDFS there is no no routing
to the dashboard yet and this is what we
do is tap steps come from wiretapping
and this is a tap symbol here and we're
able to to take an existing stream like
the one on the previous slide and then
reroute it to another thing and what we
do here is we reroute that stream to
gemfire so now the data is being both
stream to HDFS for storage and to
gemfire for for the real-time dashboard
okay now so what we do is in spring XD
we get the data from HTTP p we applied
some transformers to the data we then
put it in the python module where the
real time scoring happens with the
output balls from the sensor raw sensor
values we get from the car and the model
predictions we start off since hgss but
we also have this tap i just mentioned
that that goes into gemfire and from
gemfire goes to the dashboard via REST
API but the data that is stored in HDFS
we actually use PI spark which is the
python the python api to spark to run
the models on on on hadoop using pi
thought but a bit later about this we
don't because we don't actually use ml
liban in pi spark but we use PI spark as
a parallel driver for sidekick learn to
Train models parallel over data that is
stored on Hadoop and it's a fairly
useful tool to do that and all the all
the items here in green we had to write
code for but the rest of the items are
handled by spring XD so we did not have
to write a single line of code for that
now before I explain a data science
portion of this how this works let's
just check back with Maxine where is
maxime can you hear us we we want we
want to check we want to check where you
are heading okay so you're driving down
the way or a 1200 here we can see okay
okay so you're you're a little bit in in
the London traffic's right now okay but
but we can see you're making some
progress you're bribing you're driving
about 14 miles right now right okay are
you slow down again okay when we when we
look at the predictions are so the model
has a range of predictions now so number
five here is actually the conference
location where where we are at which at
the moment has a probability of thirty
two percent of him going there this is a
flower market is also according to the
model very likely was forty-two percent
he could potentially go to victoria park
this is actually our office up here and
in down here we have the emc office
which is our mother mother company and
down here that's Maxine's boss house now
we've we've recorded these drives
especially for four PI data to
illustrate of course there's only five
destinations here but the model can can
scale up to really many more
destinations and many more drives okay
so back to the presentation will check
back with maximum in a little bit I will
go back to the data science okay so data
science wise how does all of this work
what we really want to do is in the
first step predict a journey now let me
define a journey journey is really a
trip from the moment you turn on your
car you switch on the engine you start
streaming data and then you drive
somewhere and you turn you park your car
and turn it off again that's one journey
and we're really trying to predict
whether you're currently driving on this
journey from that journey we can one
infer where you're going going to go
because we know the end location of that
type of journey and we know your typical
driver behavior on that journey so we
know how much fuel you use we know we
know a lot of things okay so so how do
we do this first of all I can say we
store the sensor data in HDFS and this
for the for the particular drives we did
here no known this is what it looks like
these these are the different drives we
did we recorded data for here in this
area of London now now the next step is
we train the models offline and batch
using pi spark and we actually have a
pipeline of models so we have three
models in a pipeline and we periodically
retrain these models and then we push
them into the real time real time
scoring pipeline into spring XD the
first model is actually a clustering
model so unsupervised learning model and
we do this because if you if you look at
this this these are these are only one
one one sort of just so we only took one
trip here para destination but in
reality if you keep recording dry drives
for example somebody drives from home to
work they'll end up having hundreds of
those journeys stored in the database
and we somehow we need to label all
these journeys that belong to one
semantic unit so like I mentioned work
from home to work or from work to home
or from work to the gym with some money
to cluster all these journeys together
and this is this is we use k-means
clustering from scikit-learn to to
basically label these journeys and with
these labels were then able to apply
supervised learning in the next two
steps to actually predict which which of
these type of journey clusters the
driver is currently on to then infer his
destination
okay and the next step is once somebody
starts driving a turn on the car we try
to make an initial prediction of where
they're going because all of the sensor
data I've shown to you previously it's
the moment you turn on your car of
course like like for example the
temperature and acceleration it's not
very predictive is always going to be
the same right and that is why we have a
separate model to generate an initial
prediction of where you're going we only
use the time of day the day of the week
and your GPS starting location to do
that and with that we can already
actually generate a fairly accurate
prediction because people are animals of
habit if somebody drives to work from
from between eight and nine in the
morning on weekdays and it's that that
time span and he's getting into his car
and we know from his GPS coordinates
that it's at home we can then make a
fairly accurate prediction that he will
go go to work and this is what the
actual data looks like this is this is
not the data we've quoted in London but
this is from data I've recorded in
Berlin over almost a whole year so this
is much more data and we can see that
the probability of driving from home to
work is fairly high in the morning and
then during the day it drops off sharply
and then at night it's it's almost zero
and the opposite here is true for from
going from work to home it's very low in
the morning but then it's sharply rises
in the evening but as more and more
sensor data streams in it becomes more
and more predictive of where somebody's
going so to retake my example I talked
about earlier from home driving from
home to work in the morning if somebody
instead of taking the route he took from
you usually takes to work he started
driving on the road that goes to the
airport not this online model the third
model in our pipeline is then able to
say okay we switched so we switch these
probabilities in real time and say it
becomes much more likely now that is
actually driving to the airport instead
of to work so what we do is we take
these initial predictions and
we fade them out and say it in the
predictions from this online model that
gets that gets new and you generates a
new prediction every second based on the
current based on the driver behavior and
based on the current location and the
route the driver is taking and in this
way the model is very quickly able to
correct itself and once we predicted the
destination of somebody we can then
based on their driver behavior we can
then predict that they are deranged so
for example to take the airport example
again if somebody is always late to the
airport and when they're driving to the
airport they accelerate and brake very
roughly we get there obviously going to
have much less of a range than if they I
don't know visit the visitor in Los
where they drive very slowly and this is
this is the we also generate the
predictions in JSON format so this is
only a small chunk of the predictions we
basically have the cluster label so for
example this zero could significant if I
work to home we have the end location
and we have the miles per gallon that
usually the driver usually consumes on
that journey and we have the current
probability that that that drivers on
that journey so that's the output of
this third online prediction model so
let's recap the architecture here start
with a phone stream the data into spring
XD then we start in in a group data data
persistence we do run the batch training
in spark but using Python scikit-learn
we push the models back into the real
time pipeline for evaluation where the
evaluation is then also stored again at
pivotal HD so we can see how how the
models are actually doing and then we
push it to the dashboard which we just
saw
okay let me go into a little bit of
detail how how we use PI spark as I
mentioned in the beginning we actually
we don't use ml lips so that's the
that's the libes machine learning
library of spark that scales very much
to very large amounts of data but
instead we use cycle learn to to learn
the models but we use PI spark as a as a
way to push the pious barcode where the
data lives on HDFS so we can learn many
models in parallel because the data we
have is actually not that large but if
we have many cars we need too many
drivers say we need to estimate one
model paired driver so there's many
models being estimated in parallel in a
real-life use case so that is why we
chose this convenience of cyclic learn
over over the ML lip library and and you
may ask yourself so why why didn't we
use spark streaming for all of this and
and spark of course doesn't support
through real-time streaming it supports
only mini batches and they're not
they're not fast enough for for this
type of real-time use cases and sui
hence we load data into a spring xt4 for
true real time scoring okay shall we
check back what Maxim is doing where is
yeah that's less a look where how he's
doing Maxime can you hear us yeah okay
where wait a second let me just open
here oh oh you're almost you're almost
he's almost oh oh you drove to the
conference wow we didn't oh we didn't
expect that Oh in the model the model
the model has actually a soul so by the
time he's gotten close to the conference
it up one after another it excluded
these locations based on his previous
driving patterns and the model is
actually correctly predicted that he's
going to the conference was a hundred
percent certainty as he was as it became
more and more clear so yeah you're
you're at the conference actually why
don't you come come in and visit us
yeah did you bought the car oh okay
hopefully hopefully that won't take 20
minutes all right okay see you in a bit
then have a beer with us okay fantastic
alright so back to the oh he hung up on
me oh alright back to the presentation
okay here we go alright so that's that's
um país park now how did we build a bash
dashboard like I mentioned we have
gemfire as it is known of the
open-source version project geode it's a
patchy incubating project we use this as
basically as a cache layer for the
dashboard the dashboard can then query
this cache layer was a REST API that
gemfire provides we set up the desk
dashboard very quick quickly with your
man we used angularjs and now let's talk
about the scalability of this solution
so this this this architecture actually
scales to hundreds and thousands of
clients and we've shown this in the
field and actually it also scales to
millions of messages and just last week
the jump and sorry the spring XD team
did a benchmark and it showed that
spring XD can handle over 200 million
events per second and this is all open
source you can actually you can use brew
to install down on your macro you can
just go to spring XD site and download
it i really suggest you do it's a very
cool piece of software and yeah we can
ingest over a 100 gigabytes per minute
using this framework we've but we've
also encountered some issues regarding
the Internet of Things so one big issue
is compatibility even though this obd2
is supposed to be a standard it's not a
standard the car manufacturers don't
really treat it the same every time
we've done this was a different car
there was some sort of problem the car
sent back a message
that somehow destroyed Jason and blew
everything up or some values we're
missing or some values were infinitely
large or it's always some some new
problem so compatibility is a huge
problem there another one is
connectivity of course we of course we
lie on a cellular connection for all of
this if you're in a tunnel somewhere it
is not good another thing is security
because this is our own data we don't
care so much about security but in
reality if you wanted to deploy this in
production of course has to be very safe
you you can have data leaking out of
where somebody's driving looking into
the future at the moment we are porting
this whole demo on to cloud foundry and
kelso Cloud Foundry is an another open
source project from pivotal and this is
basically a platform as a service you
can think of it like Roku but better
version of her local you can deploy on
your own infrastructure and it's also
really nice to just scale up and deploy
apps very quickly we are working on some
additional use cases some at the moment
we're working on a project in the US
with a customer day they have a huge
fleet of trucks and we want to use this
architecture for fleet management and
also for predictive maintenance so since
we get all this telematics data we can
use machine learning to a predict when
when when it when the track will fail
and then this can we can take action on
that in real time and and for example
guide that truck to a service station
that is nearby predictive maintenance
I've already mentioned that and another
one is accidental systems if the app
recognizes for example that there has
been a crash we can we can phone phone
for example the authorities to come
rescue that person we are hiring so
we're hiring pivotal's hiring data
scientists you're not on software
engineers software developers we're
hiring promoters platform architecture
or architects and also field engineers
so if you're interested
send us your cv you can find all the job
positions at pivotally our careers and
we may have a short amount of time left
for questions yeah yeah and I hope
Maxine makes it here yes please go ahead
what Jane representation were you used
for this possibility predict using of
people was it all players from just
destination and the starting point or
something else yes watch data where you
use for running is it one driving
history or some more data for other
drivers to produce this drive ok so the
first question was first question was
what data format with data input formats
do we use for the models and the
representation yeah representations and
a second yeah and the second question is
sorry what was the second question a
second vision what would you were you
use for producing the destination for
one driver oh yeah only his history or
some yes so where we only using data
from one driver or multiple drivers for
predicting the destination so the first
question the first question is for the
first two models we didn't use the full
path but we actually only used the
information that is available at the
start and the end of the drive so to
label them and and to be to end to be
able to create this initial prediction
because of course for the initial
prediction you only have the data
available that's right answer but for
the third model the online prediction
model that we've seen it keeps updating
we use the full path so we use the full
path and for the second two models so
for the initial model and for the online
model we use random for us and for the
clustering we use k-means clustering and
the second question regarding whether we
use a multiple cuts no because we
actually want to use learn the driver
behavior of one particular driver we
only model we only generate one model /
driver not across multiple drivers so
there's a separate model for each driver
and there's Maxine is actually coming
just just some time he's coming in so
give him a round of applause here or our
driver all right I think we may be out
of time or okay one more question and
please go at yes what if a driver
doesn't have an irregular patterns and
picnic taxi or that's very difficult I
don't know you would model that I mean
there's there's company oh yeah of
course how would we model it if somebody
doesn't have regular driving patterns
such as taxi drivers now that's a very
difficult question I mean companies for
example like uber are working on that
but for us of course is not a product
this is technology demo so lucky for us
we don't have to worry about that
question maybe actually maybe one more
okay one more question then okay so as a
yes please God right so we did this in
between customer project oh yes of
course sorry so how long did it take us
to do this project we did this in
between customer project so it's hard to
say but i'd say about in total about two
months of a team of roughly six people
and you're going to be in the pub
afterwards yes certainly yes sir